وتعليقنا على امكانيه عقد قمه سلام بشان
اوكرانيا في باريس قال الكريم ان فرنسا
ليست دوله محايده ولا يمكنها ان تكون
وسيطه في تسويه الصراع كونها تشارك فيه
الى جانب اوكرانيا واكد الكريم ان الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين كان ولا يزال
منفتحا على ايه صلاه لتحقيق اهداف روسيا
بالطرق الاخرى وليس بواسطه العمليه
العسكريه الخاصه واضاف الكرملين ان الغرب
الجماعي لم يترك لروسيا خيارات اخرى وفق
تعبيره وكانت الوصف الجنل نقلت عن
دبلوماسيين اوروبيين قولهم ان حلفاء
اوكرانيا يخططون لعقد قمه عالميه
بدون روسيا وذلك بهدف حشد الدعم وتاييد
شروط كييف لانهاء الحرب
وحسب الصحيفه فان القاده الاوروبيين
يضغطون من اجل مشاركه الدولله حازت الى
جانب روسيا واتخذت موقفا محايدا وقد عبر
دبلوماسيون عن املهم في عقد القمه التي
سيدعى لها بايدن وقاده حلف النيتو قبل وقت
قصير من القمه في يوليو المقبل